en este vídeo vamos a tomar las
definiciones de ácidos y bases de
brondsted laurie que definimos en el
vídeo anterior y vamos a tratar de
explorar los conceptos de la k q caja y
también la el concepto de pk
y veremos que tan importantes son cuando
hablamos de la química de los ácidos y
las bases ok entonces tenemos una
digamos reacción genérica de una
reacción de ácido base que usamos que
usa la definición de brondsted laurie
así que ya es nuestro ácido genérico
digamos a puede ser no sé cualquier
elemento digamos y va a donar un protón
y h2o así que éste h2o es nuestra base
de bronces lowry y el h2o acepta un
protón y se convierte en h tres o más
verdad y si h adona un protón entonces
se queda simplemente con a menos que es
la base conjugada de esta forma así que
cuando la reacción alcanza el equilibrio
la tasa de la reacción digamos hacia
este lado es igual a la tasa de la
reacción contraria verdad o la digamos
la que va en sentido contrario y de
química nada general la posición del
equilibrio se describe por lo que
conocíamos por la expresión
kaiku que se define como la
concentración verdad
kaiku cae q se define como la
concentración de los productos entre la
concentración de los reactivos entonces
acá dq en este caso sería algo así
tendríamos la conoce el producto de la
concentración de los productos ok o la
multiplicación para que no se oiga raro
la multiplicación de la concentración de
los productos en este caso sería esto
dividido entre la concentración de los
reactivos que en este caso sería nuestro
ácido genérico y el agua muy bien y
entonces en este caso ya pudimos
calcular
ahora bien en este caso la concentración
del agua es constante verdad así que
podríamos pensar como que podemos
remover eso de esta expresión de la
calle cubo podríamos pensar lo que lo
podemos combinar si lo pasamos
multiplicando con digamos podríamos
considerar que cae q multiplica a la
concentración de agua y eso nos va a dar
la expresión k
muy bien entonces acá acá simplemente va
a ser la concentración de h 3
por la concentración de a menos dividido
entre la concentración del ácido entre h
es decir simplemente eliminamos la
concentración del agua justamente porque
es constante ok entonces tendríamos esta
definición de la caída dado que hemos
quitado el agua de nuestra expresión
ahora toda esta expresión cada su
utilizada perdón su utilidad es mucho
más obvia cuando aplicamos esto a una
reacción real así que la que vimos en el
vídeo anterior era justamente ésta
teníamos agua teníamos agua y lo le
agregamos ácido clorhídrico verdad hcl y
decíamos que esta reacción se iba en
esta dirección
era mucho mayor digamos como el ácido
era muy fuerte entonces la reacción
reversiva era mucho más débil verdad
entonces esto nos daba simplemente h3o
más un guión y drone yo más cloro oops
creo que esto se movió un poco disculpen
más cloro negativo verdad entonces ahí
lo tienen el cloro negativo entonces
como calcularemos la caja de esta
reacción como la calcularemos bueno pues
la caja k como quedaría cada sería la
concentración en este caso debe ser en
la multiplicación de la concentración de
los productos que sería la concentración
del guión y drone yo por la
concentración del cloro negativo ahí lo
tienen de lannion cloro dividido entre
la concentración del ácido clorhídrico
y como dijimos que el ácido clorhídrico
era justamente un ácido muy fuerte que
quiere decir que vamos a tener una gran
concentración tanto de johnny drone yo
como de el cañón de cloro verdad
entonces este número resulta ser de
aproximadamente aproximadamente 10 a las
7 es muchísimo es un número muy grande
bueno en realidad tendríamos que poner
dividido entre 1 esto ya es digamos esté
considerando digamos normalizando la la
expresión que de hecho es un número muy
muy grande y otra vez tiene mucho
sentido porque el ácido clorhídrico es
un ácido muy muy fuerte y que vamos a
tener mucha una alta concentración de
productos a partir de nuestros reactivos
y por eso es que esta expresión que nos
da una idea relativa de qué tan fuerte
es un ácido en este caso el ácido
clorhídrico es muy fuerte así que el
ácido clorhídrico justamente por eso va
a tener una expresión acá
muy alta ok entonces esta expresión es
de 10 a las 7 y es a las 7 y es un
número muy grande y usualmente cuando
estamos calculando estos valores ca
obtenemos números extremadamente grandes
o extremadamente pequeños que pueden ser
bastante molestos cuando estamos
trabajando con con los números o las
matemáticas y que justo cuando estamos
hablando de la de la acidez de un
compuesto nos es muy útil así que para
evitarnos esa molestia los químicos han
tomado algo que conoce lo que llaman
como el pk a ok peka peka a que
simplemente es el tomar el valor acá y
aplicarle menos logaritmo entonces es
menos logaritmo de la expresión cada y
este logaritmo por supuesto es en base
10 ok entonces esta es la pk en este
caso que tenemos cuánto vale la
expresión pk para esta reacción pues
tendríamos tendríamos la teca
sería menos logaritmo de cada que en
este caso es 10 a las 7 y esto
simplemente pues por las reglas de los
logaritmos es menos 7 muy bien de esta
forma los valores posibles que puede
tener el pk van desde menos 10 hasta 50
muy bien en este caso por supuesto
obtuvimos menos 7 pero lo mejor que
puede hacer es menos 10 y lo mayor puede
ser 50 ok entonces para todos todos los
compuestos que empecemos a trabajar
usualmente van a estar en este rango y
otra vez es mucho más fácil trabajar con
estos números es matemáticamente
mientras más más alto sea este número de
aquí por ejemplo aquí teníamos 10 a las
7 y entonces el pk salió de menos 7
quiere decir que mientras más chico sea
el valor pk este este ácido va a ser
mucho más fuerte y en caso contrario
matemáticamente podemos ver que mientras
más grande sea el valor pk quiere decir
que el ácido es más
así que hagamos otro ejemplo para
aplicar esta habilidad que ya ya tenemos
y por ejemplo consideramos el etano
vamos a considerar el etano y el etano
como ya hemos estado viendo es tomar dos
átomos de carbono y cada uno unido a
puros hidrógenos verdad entonces tenemos
estos seis hidrógenos ahí tienen el
etano y vamos a compararlo con el etanol
que tiene una estructura muy similar son
nuevamente dos carbonos cada uno de
estos tiene un enlace con con o más bien
tiene varios enlaces con hidrógenos pero
este carbono de aquí en vez de unirse en
este digamos en esta rama con un
hidrógeno se va a unir con un oxígeno y
luego con un hidrógeno verdad entonces
esto justo es lo que distingue a los
alcoholes y en este caso es el etanol
así que aquí tenemos ya dos estructuras
de puntos y si pensamos sobre la acidez
de estas dos moléculas de hecho
podríamos ver primero qué justamente
cada una de estas dos moléculas va a
donar protones y es un ácido en el
sentido de bronce dlouhy verdad así que
en términos de donar un protón podríamos
decir que es un ácido pero cuando nos
fijamos en el etanol y todos todos sus
hidrógenos en realidad este es el que se
puede donar en este caso pues puede ser
cualquiera verdad pero vamos a
considerar este ahora bien uno puede
buscar que el valor pecado del etano es
de aproximadamente 50 mientras que el
valor pk del etanol es de
aproximadamente 16 entonces que nos está
diciendo esto justamente que nos dice
que el metano es muy muy débil en
comparación del etanol
ahora bien podría sonar tentador restar
estos dos números así que para saber qué
cuál es la diferencia digamos de la
acidez y uno podría pensar bueno 50
menos 16 nos dan 34 y uno estaría
tentado a decir que el etanol es 34
veces más ácido que el etano pero no es
así en realidad son 34 órdenes de
magnitud más ácido que el etano así que
en realidad el etanol es 10 a la 34
veces más ácido que el etanol lo cual es
un número extremadamente grande y para
términos prácticos bueno para propósitos
prácticos el etanol es ácido pero el
etano no es tan ácido como el otro
verdad y otra vez estos son valores
relativos así que el etanol es mucho más
ácido que el etano pero el etanol no es
tan nacido como el ácido clorhídrico
verdad del ácido clorhídrico tenía un
pecado de menos 7 entonces es mucho más
ácido el ácido clorhídrico y el etanol
de hecho casi ni siquiera lo
consideramos como un ácido verdad
entonces hay que recordar que estos
valores son siempre relativos pero los
valores pecanas son realmente
importantes y veremos que aparecen en
muchas ocasiones en los cursos de
química orgánica ahora en el próximo
vídeo vamos a hablar de cómo es que esta
diferencia tan grande se puede calcular
entre el etanol y el etanol